With this answer, the rate of change of the number of recovered persons would be negative,
meaning that that number shrinks.
This cannot be true. That number has to grow, so we can rule out this answer.
This derivative of a number of persons with respect to time
has to be something about persons per days.
It cannot be days times persons, so this cannot be true.
The remaining two answers are correct in that respect.
This answer which need to unbound its exponential growth. This works like compound interest.
The rate of change is proportional to the current value. This cannot be true.
So we are left with this answer, which make sense.
For instance, if we have twice the number of infectious persons, this rate would go up
by a factor of 2--twice as many persons will recover per day.
And imagine you have 5,000 infectious persons, then you get a recovery rate
of 5,000 persons/5 days, 1,000 persons per day that recover.
These 5 days seem to be something like a typical duration for the disease.
So this is right answer.